did you know that 11:00 wasn't supposed
to survive past the first season of
stranger things we dug up some
interesting facts I could have
completely changed the show everyone is
devouring on Netflix wait until you see
what the original demo Gorgon looks like
we'll get to that in a minute for now
let's start with the location of the
story the Montauk Project many fans had
no idea that stranger things was
originally set in Montauk New York
that's right in 2015 Netflix announced
that the show was set to take place in
1980 in Montauk Long Island's most
eastern point Montauk is known for its
wineries and beach homes so that already
sets it apart from Hawkins Indiana which
is where the show is actually set can
you imagine wills mom hanging those
Christmas lights in a beach house
overlooking the water the Montauk
location was inspired by secret
government experiments that took place
in camp hero a state park located on
Montauk Point from the 1960s to the
1980s they were called the Montauk
Project the story about 11:00 and the
demo gorgon coming into contact and
opening a portal to the upside down
originates from an incident in the
Montauk Project conspiracy theorists say
that there is an incident in 1983 that
ended these secret experiments
apparently the US military had been
conducting these experiments on children
like 11 for 40 years the deafer brothers
said that while they loved the idea of
setting stranger things in a coastal
town they had to choose a different
location due to logistical production
reasons they said it in Indiana within
any where USA feel to it the name of the
show so now we know that the show is
said to be based on events that may or
may not have happened in Montauk New
York presumably for this reason the
original title of the show was Montauk
can you imagine those red neon letters
during the title sequence reading
Montauk instead of stranger things
sources say they weren't too keen on
changing the name in fact they called it
Montauk right up until the airdate so
how did they arrive at stranger things
apparently it was the only other name
the creators could stomach the creative
staff at Netflix made a list of
alternative titles before they decided
on Stranger thing
said that Zephyr hated all the names on
that list he said that he hopes the list
of alternate titles never ever comes out
on the Internet he told everyone that if
they leaked the list he will hurt them
casting in the beginning there was a
question of whether to hire kid actors
who had some experience or just do an
open call to all kids regardless of
their acting experience they ultimately
decided to stick with kids who had
acting chops and had performed
professionally before even with that
filter on the casting process they saw
over 2,000 kids internationally for the
major kids roles open several of the
actors had been on Broadway before
namely Jaden matarazzo who had performed
in Priscilla Queen of the desert and
they miserably we found a video of him
singing bring him home from lei Missouri
blah and he really does have a gorgeous
singing voice Millie Bobby Brown was on
a BBC miniseries called intruders Finn
Wolford had also been in a TV show
called supernatural it's hard to imagine
what stranger things would have been
like with less experienced actors
particularly for the role of 11 that
role would have been hard to pull off
for a newbie casting director Carmen
Cuba said that they always knew it was
ambitious to expect that they would find
kids that were going to be able to pull
these roles off it seems they found the
perfect cast for the show
Elevens escaped in early drafts of the
stranger things pilot 11 unleashed her
powers very early in the story she used
her telekinetic powers to free herself
from the lab and it was intense but
instead the duffer brothers decided to
tease it out for a bit and surprise
audiences with how powerful 11 actually
is so they left the escape up to the
viewers imagination Matt Duffy explained
that the idea was to slowly reveal the
extent of Elevens powers over the season
he said in the original script they sold
to Netflix 11 was hunted by agents and
she exploded a door right off its hinges
and this was all in the first episode as
soon as they started mapping out the
season realizing they had 8 hours to
fill they scaled it back a bit matt said
they built an entire backstory for 11
and then dropped those puzzle pieces in
throughout the first season
Ross added that when they finally did
reveal eleven spool powers it had more
impact they started with very small
things and built it up through the
episodes so by episode six you know a
lot about her Steve Harrington in the
beginning of season one everyone hated
Steve Harrington he seems totally
indifferent to the fact that barb has
gone missing he tries to convince Nancy
to lie about the party in the interest
of protecting himself then he and his
friends make fun of Nancy after he sees
her hanging out with Jonathan to top it
all off he broke Jonathan's camera okay
Jonathan kind of deserved it but still
we all agreed Nancy was way too good for
Steve but he totally redeems himself by
the end of the season he apologizes to
Nancy and helps them go after the demo
gorgon he also advised Donathan a new
camera which was pretty sweet for a bad
boy with awesome hair he could have gone
the way Billy did in the series but he
turned a major corner Billy's presence
really highlighted Steve's growth in the
show the deafer brothers shared that Joe
Curie the actor who plays Steve had a
lot to do with the character development
but can you imagine what the show would
have been like if Steve never evolved
from the douchey high school cool guy
this story would have been way different
11 wasn't supposed to survive in October
2018 the companion book stranger things
world's turned upside down was released
revealing insider facts about the show
the Defra brothers shared that their
original story plan for the series was
quite a bit different than the show we
all know according to Ross tougher
eleven wasn't supposed to survive the
first season Ross said 11 was going to
sacrifice herself to save everyone from
the demo gorgon once they realized the
show was getting picked up for more than
one season they decided to leave things
more up in the air Ross said that deep
down they knew the show just wouldn't be
the same without eleven and they knew
how special milli was everyone agreed
that Elevens presence was crucial going
forward with the series so what would
have happened if 11 didn't make it in
season 1
can you imagine stranger things without
this iconic character also apparently
Sean Astin's character Bob Newby was
supposed to me
his demise a lot sooner in the series
the duffer brothers said that Shawn was
so likable they felt they had to push
his goodbye to a few more episodes
they said they kept wanting him to be
alive this show that almost wasn't after
directing a low-budget straight-to-video
horror film that took four years to
release the Deaf her brother started
pitching their idea for stranger things
to studios when they did the show was
rejected by over 15 networks studios
didn't like the fact that it's a science
fiction and horror show that focuses on
a bunch of kids as the main characters
studio executives told the duffer
brothers to either make the tone of the
show more kid-friendly or shift focus to
an adult character like sheriff hopper
they liked the idea of hopper played by
David Harbor investigating paranormal
activity around town Matt and Ross
tougher refused insisting that doing
what they suggested would take away
everything interesting about the show
they were ready to give up on stranger
things right before Netflix got wind of
the show's premise and picked it up they
signed the duffer's to write direct and
produce the show proving that it can pay
off to invest in unknown talents
stranger things across the decades the
stranger things that we all know and
love was almost completely different
after the first season came out fans
wondered if the show would continue the
storyline with the same characters
location and time frame or was it
possible that the show's creators would
follow in the veins of the shows like
American Horror Story Fargo or American
crime story the premise with these shows
is that they follow a different set of
unrelated stories and characters each
season that would mean that our journey
with 11 Dustin will Mike and Lucas would
have come to an end after season 1 but
the Defra brothers liked the idea of
making a sort of 8 hour movie they
wanted to follow the storyline through
however they did consider setting each
new season in a different decade so
since season 1 was set in the 1980s
season 2 would have been set in the
1990s in season 3 4 & 5 would have
represented the 2000s 2010s and finally
2020s but they fell in love with the
world they created and wanted to
continue on the journey with these kids
we're sure we speak for everyone when we
say good call
CGI the Defra brothers are huge fans of
movies from the 80s they loved movies
like ET the extra-terrestrial jaws and
Star Wars so they wanted to honor those
genres by using as little CGI as
possible the duffer's believe that
computer-generated special effects just
didn't have the same effect as the
practical effects of these big
blockbuster movies from the 80s they
pointed to the fact that JJ Abrams used
real props in Star Wars The Force
awakens and it worked really well their
intent was to blend real with CGI
effects their goal was to use 20% CGI
and 80% practical effects but with the
short shooting schedule and the demands
of the story they weren't able to pull
off that ratio they eventually settled
on about 50% CGI effects for the final
product it's hard to make a demo gorgon
stretch the wall given the time
constraints however the production
designer did spend a lot of time hunting
down authentic props online from eBay
they found things like Trapper Keepers
and toys from the eighties that gave the
show the same feel as those classic
films from the time period justice for
barb if fans had it their way
barb would have met with a different
fate on the show even the creators were
pretty bummed when they had to sacrifice
barb to move the story along typically
in horror movies the rebellious
teenagers who are engaging in
questionable acts are the first to go
but while Nancy was upstairs making even
more bad decisions our innocent barb was
being snagged by the demo Corrigan it
goes against everything the audience was
expecting which is the good girls and
guys are spared and the bad kids are
sacrificed to the monsters the Defra
brothers admitted that the creative team
would often shake their heads and
remorse saying poor barb fans agreed and
even started a campaign with a hashtag
justice for barb fans like Franz
Buffington posted that he went for a
late night pool swim but it didn't feel
right he wrote it was still too soon and
that he can't believe we lost her so
abruptly followed by the hashtag hashtag
justice for barb we feel you Brent's
barb was like the best friend we all
wish we had in high school the original
demo gorgon the mythology of the
gorgon goes back centuries but in the
show the kids first mentioned the demo
Gorgon during a game of Dungeons and
Dragons
while the creature goes back hundreds of
years the D&D version of the demonic
beam is an 18-foot tall monster with a
scaly reptile body tentacles forearms
and two huge baboon heads it was called
the prince of demons and even in the
game it was the stuff of nightmares
but the creators of the show deviated
from the D&D version of this monster
instead of two giant baboon heads they
went with a faceless petal head that
folds in and opens up revealing a bunch
of little terrifying teeth how do you
know if it's not just a lizard because
its face opened up but he ate my cat
what do you think would have been
scarier a reptile with - baboon heads or
the petal headed demon from the show
tell us in the comments below thanks for
watching the things be sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell to be the
first to see our latest videos see you
later
[Music]